الى ملف حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا حيث عدا
ليتصدر التطورات الميدانيه الوضع في مدينه
التي تشكل محور القتال الملتهب في الجبهه
الشرقيه مع تصريحات روسيه بان باخمت تحت
الحصار في المقابل المحاولات فشله ذلك
الحصار عبر زياره الرئيس الاوكرانيه
المفاجئه للمدينه
ويعتبر الجيش الاوكراني المعركه من اجل
مدينه باخمت اساسيه من اجل صد القوات
الروسيه على طول الجبهات الشرقيه
وافادت وسائل اعلام الروسيه عن اندلاع
معارك في مختلف مناطق باخموت مشيره الى ان
اعنفها يدور في منطقه تاريخوفو
شمال غرب المدينه وقالت ان قوات
الاوكرانيه تحاول ارسال تعزيزات الى
باخموت من مدينه كوسفانتينوفكا بينما
تستمر القوات الروسيه في قصف طرق الامداد
وكانت سلطات دنيا المواليه لروسيا اعلنت
سيطره قوات باينار على 70% من اراضي
باخموت عن محاصره المدينه من جميع
الاتجاهات
وتشهد بخمه اطول المعارك واكثرها دمويه
منذ بدايه حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا في
فبراير شباط عام 2022
قد تحولت الى معركه استنزاف عسكريه وبشريه
لكلاء الطرفين يواصل الجيش الروسي
محاولاته لاحكام الطوق على بخموت خصوصا من
المحورين الشمالي والجنوبي في المقابل
يدفع الجيش الاوكراني عن يدافع عن وسط
مدينه باخموت ويسعى الى تخفيف الضغط على
طريق الامداد الرئيسي لهذه المدينه ومع
احتدام المعارك في باخموت التي كانت تضم
80 الف نسمه قبل اندلاع الحرب طلبت اللجنه
الدوليه للصليب الاحمر بضروره توفير
مساعدات عاجله للسكان في المدينه وفي
مقابله مع الجزيره قال المتحدث باسم
اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر ان الوضع
الانساني في بخموت شديد والصعوبه
كنت ضمن قفيلتين للجنه الدوليه للصليب
الاحمر في المنطقه المحيطه ببخمت الوضع
الانساني هناك يصعب تصديقه من الصعوبه
بمكان ان نصف مستوى الضمائر هناك ولا يمكن
لاحد ان يتخيل كيف تمكن المدنيون من
البقاء في الظروف الصعبه هناك لقد شهدت في
قريه بمحيط بخموت وجود الف مدني وهم بحاجه
ملحه جدا للمساعدات الانسانيه لذلك من
المهم للمنظمات الانسانيه ان تصل لهؤلاء
الاشخاص ومدهم بالمساعدات الضروريه
[موسيقى]